We all know that a good story can move us,
make us feel something,
teach us something,
help us be better at something.
But can a story literally move us,
that is get us to move and be healthy?
Today, we'll learn the answer to this
question in many other best practices for
what makes a good story.
I'm Matt Abrahams and
I teach Strategic Communication at
Stanford Graduate School of Business.
Welcome to Think Fast Talk Smart,
the podcast.
We are so
lucky today to be joined by Paula Moya.
Paula is the Dan Lee and
Laura Louise Bell,
Professor of the Humanities and
a Professor of English at Stanford.
She also is a recipient of the Dean's
Award for distinguished teaching.
Paula has several books on the market,
the most recent being
the Social Imperative Race, Close Reading,
and Contemporary Literary Criticism.
For the past two years, she's been part of
a research project that investigates and
validates using narrative to encourage
individuals to increase their activity
levels to improve health span.
Welcome, Paula, I am so
eager to work with you.
>> Thank you, Matt, I'm so
glad to be here and
to have an opportunity to chat with you.
>> Great, let's get started.
Before we get into some of the really
cool ways, you're using stories to
motivate people, I'd like to start with
some general questions about stories.
You are a narratologists,
I've never heard that term before,
can you define what that means and
what do you do?
>> [LAUGH] Well, narratology basically
is just a study of narratives and
narrative structure, and the ways that
these things affect human perception.
So, narratologists basically is
just someone who does the studying.
I've always loved reading and
I'm captivated by stories.
And so it's been my pleasure
over the last decade or so,
to be able to spend time thinking
about what makes narrative work.
>> Wow, a whole field I was unaware of.
So as somebody who studied
narratives as deeply as you have,
I'm curious from your perspective,
what makes a good narrative or story?
>> I guess I'd have to say that a lot
depends on what anyone means by good,
right?
So [LAUGH] I love many different kinds
of stories and I know that they all draw
on different kinds of elements
to give them their value.
But the basic elements of a story,
we can start there, of a story or
a narrative or plot, so what happens,
character's, point of view or
perspective, and
that relates to focalization.
Setting, where it's located, scene,
kind of basically what they're
talking about, and of course, style.
So conflict is also central to any
story because there always needs to be
something that kind of gets the story
going and powers the events that occur.
So these elements will always be
present in any particular story,
albeit in different combinations and
with different emphases.
So a good story or
narrative will have all of those, but
it's important to know from my
perspective that what one person defines
as good may be very different from what
some other person defines as good.
So what good is will be very much
influenced by what someone knows,
what they value, what they love,
and also what they recognize.
And this is sometimes cultural, right,
based on where someone grew up,
what they are accustomed to
doing in their daily lives.
And it's also sometimes learned, right,
based on what we were taught in school,
right, what did our teachers tell us.
Or even what someone we
admire says it's good, so
maybe a preacher or a mother or an aunt.
So for example,
those of us who read a lot of stories or
consume a lot of narratives, and so
I count myself among those because
I'm always reading or
watching some cereal or something.
When we do that, we can easily become
bored by characters we proceed and
stock characters for
plots that are predictable.
if you read enough narratives, you start
to recognize certain particular turns.
And we get bored by them because we've
seen them too many times before and
they contain for us, no surprises.
At the same time, for someone else, that
same story can be fresh and interesting.
So my answer kind of to like what's good,
what makes a good narrative is that
a story is good if someone
somewhere values it as good.
Now, it just might not be good for me
[LAUGH] so and I'm making a larger point
about the existence of multiple
conceptions of the good.
>> Certainly, I hear you talking
about several things, for example,
you need to think about who your story is
for and what's going to be interesting,
relevant, and exciting for them.
>> Yes.
>> And you need to be careful,
I heard also of falling into
the trap of using common clichés or
common ways of telling the story or
designing the story.
I heard you talk about surprise,
I heard you talk about a novelty,
or at least I'm applying
novelty to what you said,
to really make it something that stands
out, would you agree with those?
>> I would completely agree with that.
So it's kind of a mix of making
it familiar, which we like.
Just as human being, psychologically,
we have a kind of principle of familiarity
that drives us and also making it new,
making them a little surprising, giving
us something that is not predictable.
So, but this kind of goes back to
the first thing that you picked up on,
which is that we always have to think
about who this narrative is for,
because what's going to work is going to
be different according to who it's for.
>> Absolutely, and that is a theme we have
heard many times on this podcast about
really reflecting on our audience for
our communication.
Should we approach crafting stories
meant to be read differently
from those that we speak?
>> Absolutely, I really agree
with that because you know it is.
If you're listening to a story, you
might need a heavier dose of repetition,
to help your listener to keep
track of what is happening.
And so you see this in sort of
storytelling cultures where there's often
a great deal of repetition and they
come back to certain kinds of motifs, so
like a certain image or a certain color.
And if you're listening to story,
you can't go back and
look something up, right?
>> Right.
>> So you need the storyteller to help
you by drawing you along with these
repeated motifs, these repeated words, and
also reminders of who is who and
how they are related to their characters.
And I think it's probably a little
easier to have a more complex
narrative in writing than listening.
>> I really want to emphasize this point.
In the work that I do, there's a really
big challenge that people have, they
write as if they're writing their content
to be read, and then they speak it.
And it just sounds different,
it doesn't connect the same way.
>> [LAUGH]
>> A lot of the ideas that you suggested,
those are all things that can really
help a story stand out when spoken,
and similarly might seem redundant or
repetitive or
short sighted in a written piece.
So the big message is we
have to envision writing for
speaking and writing for
being read is very different things and
I think that point is super important
>> It absolutely is and
I'm glad that you are articulating it so
clearly, I need to learn from you.
>> [LAUGH] No, well, I do a lot of
speaking, so I repeat myself a lot,
much to my family's dismay
>> [LAUGH] But
let me just say one more thing about
that is that, always when we're
thinking about communicating,
we need to think about the medium, so
what is the medium through
which we are communicating?
So obviously, a novel is a different
medium than say a story circle where
you're sitting around talking to people.
The medium really that it makes it so
important to sort of shift how you do
something if you want to communicate well
>> So
true, I cannot tell you the number
of times I see people try to
tell stories through bullet
points on PowerPoint slides.
And it's the wrong medium, it's the wrong
tool to get your message across and
I really appreciate that advice.
I'd like to turn to your research,
your research and
writings focus on race and culture.
Do you have any guidance on how we
can be more inclusive of diversity
in the stories we choose to tell and
how we actually craft those stories?
>> Well, I think probably the easiest way,
the most simple way to be inclusive
diversity is also the most obvious way.
That is to write or consume stories
about those people, places,
events, and dilemmas that are for
the most part absent or
underrepresented in
the mainstream of society.
So they're not, for example, sufficient
representations of Latinx people in
the media, television theater, the movies
and journalism, to give a true and
accurate picture of the richness and
the complexity of Latino life.
This is not to say that there is none.
Just to say that there was a dearth
of such representation relative to
the number of Latinx people
living in this country.
And unfortunately, many of the
representations of Latinx people are quite
negative and stereotypical.
And so not representative,
the wide range of experiences of people
who are associated with that ethnicity.
>> So it certainly sounds to me like,
if you're looking to be more inclusive
in the stories you tell, you need to
tell stories that include people,
that by definition,
I think is what we're talking about.
But we also have to be sensitive
to what we represent and
what we tell those stories about.
So it's not just including people in
the stories, it's what those stories
are about and the focus and what the
message they send beyond the story itself.
And that's really important for
all of us to think about.
As we live in a more diverse culture,
it's critical to hear the stories and
voices of every one.
You were part of a very cool
interdisciplinary team looking at the role
of narrative in motivating
positive health behavior,
can you tell us briefly
about the Perfecto Project?
>> So the Perfecto Project is actually
an extension of a larger project
involving a very large interdisciplinary
team at Stanford University.
There has been researching the
effectiveness in motivating mobility of
narrative based feedback that is
delivered on the ambient screen of
an Android smartphone.
So basically, that just means it's
a mobile mobility app that helps
takes the user through a narrative.
And as the user exercises or walks or
does some kind of physical activity,
the story moves along, so
they help power the story in that sense.
>> It sounds to me like
it's a fitness tracker,
the data from which actually
moves you through a story, and
that story serves to help motivate
even more movement, is that right?
>> That's exactly right.
And so what we're trying to do is create
a narrative that's interesting enough that
the person wants to do their exercise so
they can get the next chapter.
>> Wow, I think for the listeners,
this notion of thinking about creating
stories that you share as a leader,
as a participant of teams
that are culturally relevant.
And the fact that you are finding that
the notion that a story can serve as
motivation for any behavior, potentially,
is really a fascinating one.
As part of the work you just described,
I read that there seems to be
a link between motivation and
empathy for characters in stories.
Can you describe this association and
any guidance that it might suggest for
those of us trying to motivate
others through the stories we tell?
>> Well, I do think empathy,
where we feel for others,
as well as things like recognition, where
we maybe see characters that remind us of
ourselves are very important for
how stories affect listeners and readers.
Because one very basic psychological
phenomenon is familiarity,
which is simply a form of remembering and
with the situation and event,
a person, a place to provokes
a subjective feeling of recognition.
So if I guess,
I've been at that tamale making party,
I've been at that birthday party where
there's where we break a piñata.
So it doesn't have to be perfect, but it
brings something out of ourselves to us.
And I think being recognized makes
us feel good, feel valued and
makes us feel a sense of belonging.
>> This notion of helping people
feel what what you're talking
about is familiar to them
is really interesting.
It really speaks to the need to
demonstrate that you understand
people's experience and
help them see how they can change
that experience,
enhance that experience, etc.
So this notion of using empathy
to demonstrate familiarity,
I think is a really interesting tool for
those of us who craft communications
to have in our toolkit.
Do you have a favorite tool
that you listen for or look for
in what you write or you read?
For example, I do, I love alliteration.
I'm curious, do you have any tools
you find that you gravitate towards
in narratives that you write or listen to?
>> That's a very interesting question.
I'm not sure that I think of it as
programmatically as that, like,
these are my tools, but I definitely use
alliteration, I find it very effective.
So a modicum of repetition, alliteration,
I will often speak my written sentences
aloud to see how they sound to me.
And then of course thinking about images,
I'm very attentive to the use of certain
words and also not reinforcing certain
associations that has been negative,
for instance, for people of color.
>> The tools you shared are really
helpful for all of us to think about.
Before we get to our closing,
I am curious if you have any last best
practices on how to craft better
stories to motivate our audiences?
>> Clearly, an author or storyteller
needs to create compelling situations and
dilemmas full of suspense and surprise,
because those are things that give us joy.
They also need to create characters
in whom we are interested in,
whether that'd be because the characters
we see ourselves in them or
because we care about them or
feel empathy for them.
Or because they operate in a field of
action that in some way intrigues us,
maybe even scares us.
>> Before we end,
I'd like to ask you the same three
questions I asked everybody, sound okay?
>> Yeah, sure.
>> All right, if you were to capture
the best communication advice
you ever received as a five to seven
word presentation slide title,
what would it be?
>> Make them want to turn the page.
>> I really liked that.
>> It is an eight word sentence, I think.
But if you're reading a novel, you want to
know either because the character or
the situation, whatever you want to know,
what's going to happen.
>> Absolutely,
it's building suspense and intrigue, and
that's important in all communication.
Let me ask you question number two.
Who is a communicator that you admire and
why?
>> I would say that Margaret Atwood
is an amazing communicator,
she is an amazing novelist,
I eagerly seek out anything she writes.
She is a beautiful user of language,
she could make me envision the world
that she was putting together.
And she also was not afraid to make
difficult characters who are real
in the sense that people like them
exist out there in the world.
>> Final question,
what are the first three ingredients that
go into a successful communication recipe?
>> I'd say sense, the story has to
make sense, humor, and then finally,
suspense, and that comes from
making them want to turn the page.
[LAUGH]
>> I like this notion of it, it just has
to make sense, right, a lot of us don't
take a simple criterion like that.
We've definitely on this podcast talked
about humor and the value of humor.
And you've illuminated today,
how suspense and
familiarity can be really, really helpful.
Paula, thank you so much for
joining us today and
sharing the story of your work, and
how to make our stories work better.
We're taking away so many important
insights that can really strengthen our
narratives and help us to motivate
people in the direction that we want.
I appreciate your time and
your insights, thank you.
>> Well, thank you, Matt, I'm very happy
to have had the chance to talk with you.
>> Thanks for joining us for
another episode of Think Fast Talk Smart,
the podcast, produced by Stanford
University's Graduate School of Business.
For more information and episodes,
visit gsb.stanford.edu, or
subscribe to our show wherever
you get your podcasts.
Finally, find us on social
media at stanford.gsb.